[Music]
it's scooted to cover the spoon and I
reached up and crack my knuckles just
praying that that answer would come to
the guard the noise he heard was me
cracking my nose in my mind it sounded
close enough he walked over and looked
down at me he looked around again
and I looked up and I could see him turn
around boy I just dodged a bullet there
was a temptation to just make a run for
it and I just decided don't push your
luck do nothing right now
and wait for the best opportunity in the
next few hours I knew that if I waited
at the hour of dawn all those people
were gonna be sleeping off an alcohol
drunken stupor
it was difficult holding myself back
as I lay there I imagine slipping that
link off
I imagine where I was going to head I
imagine I was gonna find a way
I'm feeling very good for feeling like
I'm gonna be able to do this
it's still night time he's kicking me in
the side kicking me awake why are they
getting me up in the middle of the night
they unshackled me ready take me there's
no way they could know I'm trying to
escape my heart is like sinking with
every step because I've missed my
opportunity to escape by hours I'm
thinking you really should have went
when you had the chance
why did you wait my thoughts are racing
there had to be a reason why they were
doing this maybe they've got the ransom
and they're going to release Remy and
I'm both that hope disintegrated quickly
I found myself being pushed from the
back by a sub aya into this this hole I
started to resist am i entering the
gates of hell
it turned out that my instincts were
right
I had that the distinct feeling that
this could be the last place on earth
that I saw I felt hands on my shoulder
sort of steadying me as if they were
preparing to to brace me for something
this was gonna be different I recognized
it right away it was a livestock needle
and I'm thinking what in the world is he
gonna do with that Joseph looked at me
and said no money you die
I had created my own monster by telling
them and giving them information about
the super cat they now believed that I
knew more and they were intent on
getting it out of me I would have peed
my pants if I hadn't been so dehydrated
I just buzzed with shock not wanting to
believe that it was happening because I
knew it was gonna end badly
damn he drove a needle right through one
of my knuckles he impaled it against the
table I felt like I was in the middle of
a tornado of anger and violence
suddenly there was no sound I was above
myself looking down feeling no pain it
was an incredible feeling of redemption
and peace and they just suddenly stopped
stood up and walked away
[Music]
and at that point I actually felt sorry
for them